Oh who goes there
Europe you're coming with us
nice and easy don't think so not that
[Music]
so let's soldier boy steel is he one of
us now he's cut balls this what was his
name again
cloud Cloud Strife right and he isn't a
soldier anymore still he's a
professional unlike the rest of us I'm
glad to have him this is a one-time gig
when it's done we're done
you better be worth the money murdered
every last kill
[Music]
this palm sole purpose is to drain the
planet dry while you sleep while you eat
while you sit it's here sucking up maca
it doesn't rest and it doesn't care you
do realize what my core is don't you
Marco is the lifeblood of our world the
planet bleeds cream like you and me
bleed red there you thinks gonna happen
when it's all gone huh answer me you
gonna stand there and pretend you can't
hear the plan cried out in pain I know
you can you really hear that damn
straight I do get help
say that again
no stay nah we can take this
that hunk of junk is Andy weapons
platform if we rushed in we got this bad
right need a hit with magic that should
give us an open
[Music]
hey boom let's pin it down but all
you've got to do it
that's our target the reactor core gotta
set the bomb at the bottom
[Music]
what's wrong
[Music]
I'm fine what about the timer
you'll call Merc
double-crossing
heads up what
hey we fight this thing it's got
reinforced armor cleaning but the
internals can be overloaded lightning
magic no adoption huh
[Music]
[Music]
got anything you wanna say
funny way to ask for help
you see the damage that did keep it up
[Music]
I'll take the lead
[Music]
that awareness
the Heather set a barrier never seen
this defense system before so the expert
Bella
[Music]
be careful
got a heal up what I have the gene
brain how on
tell me wife
[Music]
see you
[Music]
No
the bomb
ha you hear that damn thing sued you how
it's done
come on we've gotta move